und mein Thema heute Abend ist der
Quoten Wahnsinn in der Union der zu
nichts führt sie haben es vermutlich
alle mitbekommen die Frauenquote kommt
in der CDU in Niedersachsen gab es
bereits Paritätische Listen die Wahl in
Niedersachsen wurde jetzt trotz diesem
feminismus-ruck vergeigt besonders
merkwürdig 2020 hat sich noch der
Parteivorsitzende Friedrich Merz gegen
paritätisch besetzte Listen
ausgesprochen betitelte diese als
fragwürdig und sprach von einer
Diskriminierung der Männer jetzt sitzt
ja Helen immer neben mir und da frage
ich mich jetzt natürlich Herr Lindemann
werden sie denn jetzt kritisiert also
diskriminiert von ihrem eigenen
Parteichef als sein Vize durch die
Frauenquoten nein ich werde nicht
diskriminiert dafür bin ich zu
selbstbewusst nein ich bin auch kein Fan
von Quoten ich finde das Quoten auch
nicht zu CDU passen weil wir vom
einzelnen ausgehen und ihn nicht nach
äußerlichen Merkmalen definieren aber
das war eine Abstimmung es gab eine
große Debatte und ich akzeptiere jetzt
das Ergebnis
im Kern werden wir aber das was wir
eigentlich lösen müssen dass wir mehr
Frauen auch in der Politik haben auch
bei uns nicht mit einer Quote zentral
lösen können meine Vorsitzenden
Paderborn die heißt Corinna Rotte wer
mehr als 4.000 Mitglieder eine tolle
junge Frau die hat auf ein Parteitag
gesagt eine Quote wird nie sicherstellen
können dass meine Kinder von der Kita
abgeholt werden wenn ich auf einer
politischen Veranstaltung bin und damit
hat sie es auf den Punkt gebracht
konservativ rüberkommen also ich meine
die Union hat ja eh durch die
merkeljahre am Profil verloren das
glaube ich würde wenn sie mir vermutlich
zustimmen auch wenn Sie die
CDU-Politiker sind aber jetzt kommt die
Frauenquote was kommt denn als nächstes
die diversitätsquote also wo will die
CDU hin das fragt man sich ja schon als
Bürger
also das muss finde ich eine Ausnahme
bleiben es ist ein langes Thema wie
gesagt ich akzeptiere das Ergebnis ich
glaube das gehört auch dazu dass man
sich streitet und hinterher das Ergebnis
akzeptiert und die die wir müssen es
jetzt schaffen durch Formate anfangs-
und Endzeit dass das klar ist dass wenn
jemand beispielsweise im Ausland
studiert will aber trotzdem an der
Ratssitzung teilnehmen dass das auch
Hybride funktioniert dass es digital
funktioniert und vieles mehr wir als CDU
müssen jetzt insofern unsere Wurzeln
eine wichtige Wurzel haben sie
angesprochen ist die konservative
insofern prägen dass wir jetzt in
konkreter Politik das deutlich machen
und das machen wir jetzt im
Grundsatzprogramm Prozess da werden wir
jetzt im nächsten Jahr also bis Ende
September nächsten Jahres alle
Positionen durch deklarieren wie steht
ihr in der Rente wieder fällt
nee das ist eine Partei Entscheidung
aber wir werden natürlich konservative
Position haben ich bin bekannt man sich
jetzt also nicht nach der Niedersachsen
weil Mist die paritätischen Listen haben
es auch nicht gebracht hätten wir
vielleicht gar nicht gebraucht nein das
hat andere Gründe glaube ich für diese
Niederlage wenn man ein anderes Thema
nein entscheidend ist dass die CDU eine
Partei sein muss die die Bock macht auf
Zukunft wo man weiß wofür sie steht die
auch konservative Position die sie auch
mal hatte die man nicht über Bord werfen
darf jetzt die Schuldenbremse
beispielsweise ist mir viel zu wenig wir
brauchen eigentlich eine schwarze Null
dass der Staat mit dem Geld auskommt ich
weiß es immer schwierig in solchen Krise
so was auszusprechen aber deswegen mache
ich es von solchen Punkten brauchen wir
mehr eigentlich will ich das am Ende des
Tages
jedes CDU-Mitglied nachts 3 Uhr geweckt
werden kann und sofort sagt erstens
drittens dafür steht die CDU hoffentlich
ist da nicht einer der drei Punkte
direkt die Frauenquote
weitergeht aber Herr Funke da möchte ich
sie gerne einmal fragen also Deutschland
mich hat das schon sehr bewegt
Deutschland übertiert über die Gaspreise
über den Ukraine kriegt wir sind ja
wirklich in schwierigen Zeiten und dann
kriegt man plötzlich medial mit und die
CDU debattiert über die Frauenquote wie
ist es denn bei ihnen angekommen das
interessiert niemanden
außer den die in Parteien sind also ich
bin überhaupt nicht in den letzten
Monaten das heißt irgendwie muss ich
jetzt hier lange nachdenken um zu wissen
wann ich auf Frauenquoten angesprochen
worden bin aber es hat niemanden
interessiert ich finde sie nicht ganz
das Klientel für die Frauenquote ja ich
weiß nicht wenn sie überprüfen wie sehe
ich dafür gesorgt habe dass Frauen an
guten Stellen kandidierten dann würden
sie vielleicht etwas anderes darüber
reden aber es kommt das ist doch der
Punkt man muss doch praktisch von
Politik machen so und wenn Frauen Männer
manchmal keine Rücksicht darauf nehmen
dass Frauen keine Kinder zu Hause haben
das könnte ich Ihnen konkret sagen wenn
Sitzung über Gebühr lange dauern da kann
man vieles anders machen auch damit
Frauen dann auch mehr Interesse haben
oder mir geneigt sind mitzumachen weil
sie wissen es wird auch die Rücksicht
genommen nein aber die Frauenquote
interessiert doch in diesen Zeiten
niemanden
aus der Bevölkerung heraus für den
normalen Menschen den kleinen Mann die
keine Frau interessiert das Thema
überhaupt nicht oder ich habe einen
völlig falschen Bekannten und
Freundeskreis gebe zu
das sind überwiegend Leute auf dem
flachen Lande oder aus kleinen Städten
so die jeden Tag arbeiten gehen die auch
jeden Tag arbeiten gehen müssen auch die
Frauen um überhaupt einen bestimmten
Wohlstand ich sage außerdem bestimmten
Wohlstand zu erreichen und das wird in
Kreisen diskutiert mein Gott sollen sie
diskutieren aber die breite Masse
interessiert sich doch für ein
Sozialgesetz Thema nicht die haben
andere Sorgen das soll der der
Facharbeiter vom Bau dann ganzen Tag auf
dem Bauch steht nach Hause kommt und
dann soll der mit seiner Frau die
halbtags beim Bahlsen Kekse einpackt
oder sogar in Schichten dort arbeitet so
dann über die Frauenquote diskutieren
mein Gott wenn das behauptet der hat
aber jeglichen Kontakt mit den Schichten
der Bevölkerung verloren wenn Sie
zustimmen dass die große Bevölkerung ist
nicht interessiert das Thema ich glaube
tatsächlich in dem Punkt stimme ich auch
mit ihnen über eine Funke ich glaube es
ist ein bisschen wirklich so ein
Elfenbeinturm Thema das ist so ähnlich
wie die ganze Debatte übers Gendern dass
wir irgendwie in Berlin Mitte so eine
Diskussion vielleicht führen und ich
glaube wirklich die Leute haben andere
Probleme ich finde eine Sache ist mir
aufgefallen in den Beiträgen die sie
Linnemann der Funke gerade gesagt haben
dass sie beide gesagt haben naja für die
Mütter damit Frauen in die Politik
können muss es eine bessere Versorgung
mit Kitaplätzen geben
damit die Vereinbarkeit möglich ist
damit ich länger in politischen
Sitzungen bleiben kann wenn ich in die
Politik gehen möchte aber eigentlich
müssten sie doch genauso sagen damit
auch die Väter das können wieso ist das
denn nur für die Mütter ein Thema
haben beide Männer Anstoß akzeptiert
hier so gibt es Umdenken statt bei 8:15
Uhr
[Gelächter]
hier werden die die Männer schon
beigebracht